well much of the media have
mocked the existence of unidentified
flying objects the u.s pentagon has been
studying this subject for quite a long
time
and apparently we'll soon release some
of its findings which remain classified
according to a new report in the new
york times the u.s government may have
physical
evidence of and we're quoting off-world
vehicles not made
on this earth the government has
also released footage of ufo sightings
including a 2004 encounter recorded from
an advanced navy fighter jet
commander david fravor is a retired
naval aviator who once saw something
he could not explain that science can't
explain we're honored to have him on
tonight mr favor thanks so much for
coming on
so ex tell us if
you think this is being misinterpreted
according to the new york times the u.s
government has
physical evidence of some sort of
vehicle
made not on this earth is it what it
sounds like
well it sounds that way to me tucker i
just uh you know i never want to
speculate what the government truly has
but i would say there's stuff out there
i mean the four of us that chased the
the tic tac in 2004
will have attested to it multiple times
that what we saw
exceeded anything that we had in our
inventory far superior to
the airplanes that we were flying in at
the time they were brand new so
i would say yes there's something out
there and hopefully the government does
have stuff
so when we spoke before about this and
you suggested that the object you saw
that you chased the tic-tac
behaved in ways that challenged your
understanding of
of aeronautics of physics and that you
didn't think it was
likely that that object was
belong to a foreign military um do you
think the us government has concluded
that this is not russia china or some
other country
i'm pretty sure of that that you know
just by some of the phone calls that
we've gotten
some of the people that we have talked
to in the government that they are
unaware of what this is i think that
ties directly with the east coast
sighting with the gimbal video and
i'd be willing to say just because i'm
in contact with a lot of these people
that there are more incidents that are
starting to come out
that people are starting to report
inside the government channels of things
that they've seen and i think you're
seeing it from people in the past
because it always had that taboo to come
out and talk about these things
you're not finding people from the past
that are saying hey i saw this i just
was never told a reporter or when i did
i was told not to say anything
yes so i think since 2017 the world is
starting to change because of the
publicity
because of the attention of the senate
and the congress because of people like
marco rubio
and the intel committee of telling the
the dod hey i want to report
i think you're starting to see more and
more that and i would say if if if the
government does have stuff and i don't
know what they have
but if they do i would think that you
know there's probably stuff vigo roswell
was 73 years ago if something did happen
because there's a lot of speculation
that there was something
other than a weather balloon where's all
that at
i mean if just just by odds something
would be here
so that raises the question while the
secrecy i mean clearly the us government
has lied to the public
for maybe 73 years why do you think
uh well you know if we go back to like
project blue book and go
you know it was done it really did two
things one it investigated
occurrences and sightings that people
saw the other one was it primarily was
sent to out to debunk
to prove that it wasn't or to make
excuses of why it wasn't
i don't know why i think some of it was
trying to capture that technology but
if something lands in your front yard
there's no reason to deny that it
existed or
you know for the government to cover it
up because you know if it's not
collected by some
means that's going to question our
national security or
our defense or our offensive or
defensive capabilities then why would
you
hide it i i that just baffles me
just like our incident why wasn't it
thoroughly investigated at the time
for something that literally could
penetrate a battlegroup spaces and
they did nothing i mean there was
nothing done until really about 2009.
it's i mean there's a there's a story
here that a lot of us can't wait to see
finally do you feel vindicated
uh i never you could say that but i
never
you know most of fellow aviators that
know the group of us
we were never like chastised or i mean
you get ribbed but it was never like
you're crazy or anything like that right
but i know there are people that do have
that fear of coming out saying
you know that it's going to ruin their
career and for me it just wasn't
the wasn't it was never the case right
well that's that's the beauty of being a
naval aviator people take you seriously
by definition
commander thanks so much and i i try and
be sober and believable for you tucker
and you are and we appreciate it thank
you thank you